a quick update about brexit which has
always been way too cute a name for
something so destructively stupid it's
like hearing your friend decided to
shove a snake up what became known as
his smash hole no don't reward it with a
portmanteau we shouldn't have done that
stupid thing and I'm afraid at this
point um for you viewers in the UK
once again you're gonna have to get
something different because the rest of
the world is gonna see a piece about
Teresa mais provisional brexit deal but
in that piece there's gonna be some
parliamentary footage and as we've
discussed before on this show it's
against the law for a comedy program to
do that in the UK which is and this is
true for King stupids now obviously that
puts us in a little bit of a pickle as
this show now has a six minute gap that
we need to fill you may remember last
time we ran into this exact same problem
we replace the segment with Gilbert
Gottfried reading three-star Yelp
reviews for restaurants in Boise Idaho
don't worry I am NOT going to do that to
you again because this time Gilbert is
going to be reading to you from Teresa
mais 585 page provisional agreement with
the EU Gilbert my friends take it away
article 130 specific arrangements
relating to fishing opportunities as
regards the fixing of fishing
opportunities within the meaning of
article 43 parentheses 3 close
parentheses for any period falling
within the transition period the United
Kingdom shall be consulted in respect of
fishing opportunities related to the
United Kingdom you know what you know
what this was a bad idea Britain doesn't
deserve this I didn't realize it was
gonna be this bad when I originally made
the decision to do this but if we've
learned one thing phone breaks it's that
an entirely reversible decision cannot
actually be reversed so Gilbert please
continue
article 11 single electricity market the
provisions of union law governing
wholesale electricity markets
listed in annex 7 to this protocol shall
apply under the condition set out there
in - and in the United Kingdom in
respect of Northern Ireland next article
12 know what you know what you know what
let's let's martyr heads prevail here
let's have a people's vote and have our
audience choose between listening to
Gilbert read this and listen to read
something a little bit more fun like
Bigfoot erotica so which is it to be the
EU draft treaty or the short work of
Bigfoot erotica Yeti set go I thought so
sadly there cannot be a people's vote on
this so Gilbert please continue with
article 12 article 12 state aid the
provisions of union law listed in annex
8 to this protocol shall apply to the
United Kingdom including with regard to
major supporting the production of and
trading agricultural products in
Northern Ireland in respect of measures
that effect I trade between the part of
the territory of the United Kingdom to
which regulation parentheses EU close
parentheses I can't I can't do this my
people in England are suffering enough
Gilbert's tell them about the big foot
picture the scene I a young nubile
wildlife photographer found myself lost
deep in the woods face to face with the
one they called Bigfoot let me tell you
it's true what they say about big feet
because standing before me was half-man
half-beast
his musk of moss and cedar hung in the
air his barrel chest heave and between
his legs swung what I can only describe
as a glistening furry forest lawn
[Applause]
picture of mink
biting an apple my mouth instinctively
dropped open in surprise and if I'm
honest anticipation this is going to be
the Loch Ness monster all over again
okay goober that's time change the law
UK or you'll get chapter two
next time
you